this is a portrait of England and Wales
at work 27.8 million of us the sorts of
jobs we do the sorts of economy we are
and how all that is changing so by far
the most common job in England Wales is
a sales or retail assistant 1.1 million
people four percent of the working
population then you've got over 850 000
people in the care sector in third place
the most common profession was cleaner
or domestic assistant now some jobs skew
older have a look at those demographics
here these are people aged 65 plus the
highest proportion was elected
representatives and then you've got a
changing of the profession so this is a
traditional profession typist they tend
to be on you can see data entry seems to
be taking over here a lot younger now
you still have a lot of gender provide
this is 97 of people working Early
Education and child care workers are
women and that is a very gendered
Workforce but then you get other ones
which are more heavily male dominated 99
of bricklayers are men that that's true
across all sorts of construction and
Engineering Industries 98 of vehicle
mechanics here you go uh are men as well
those gender splits aren't fixed in two
in stone they are changing too 75
percent of science research engineering
and Technology those occupations Were
Meant overall but if you look at how
it's changing uh in terms of engineering
you can see there are a lot more women
coming through so that might be another
Changing of the Guard